and i've i've played like three
youtube-worthy videos
it's a very youtube-worthy stream
because we had the um the game against
brigham
this crazy stockfish confusing position
and then this queen double queen sack
miniature
stafford sac mates game
okay let's play opponent wants a draw no
draw
a general piece of advice when
the opponent offers a draw it usually
means they're scared hello
and you should play on throw in
oh thank you what's doom and mr suez
oh my queen no
i was expecting b takes and d takes is a
little bit stranger
oh i feel so broken i was on such a
good like nice hot streak and now
life is falling apart
do i offer a draw
when my opponent offered to draw it gave
me a false
sense of confidence
so i'm trying to do the same
also i should note like offering a draw
is usually bad etiquette
um but i did it for the meaning
okay let's play this move i want to play
this move
okay now i feel like nejmedinov please
play this or this
or this
doesn't again matter how like a video
where nejmedina like sacked a queen to
just weaken the dark squares
it wasn't quite like this draw
okay another fun fact you should never
take a draw
actually no i'll think about it
contemplate
okay so the fun fact is you should never
take a draw
when it's your opponent's turn because
there is potential to just win
um so now the question is
how much do i want to risk
if i take i'm down a piece
yeah i should take a draw here i'm down
on time too i'm just down the full piece
and the pawn
and there's very few tricks
that was a terrible what was that game
i blundered the queen but then black
blundered it back
what was this i got so excited too
because this is a
like this is a main move and then this
is a fun variation
um yeah this was nifty
because i saw the potential for bishop
g5
and if black doesn't take then there's
an e4 coming maybe
okay that might also have to go on
youtube
i have like a whole weeks of youtube
content
for this like few hour stream